today's topic adam levine adam levine is
that like the guy from maroon 5 yep okay
i'm just gonna rip band it off because
i've retaken this like 10 times now
essentially
i was having an affair with a man who's
married to a victory secret model at the
time you know i was
young i was naive and
i mean quite frankly i feel exploited i
wasn't in the scene like i am now um so
i was definitely very easily manipulated
how old was she this was less than a
year ago how old is she she's like 23
22.
this was less than a year ago carry on
you feel
now that you were manipulated because
you didn't have what you wanted that's
what it is you want to justify
all the flags that you bypassed
by saying i was manipulated you just
don't want your you that's lack of
accountability right there i was young
and i was a year ago girl you were not
15 you were 23.
if we
if we know
[ __ ] got to take accountability
or got a little bit of logic okay you're
23. you're way past the age to vote
you're way past the age to go to the in
the army and kill you can have a license
you can have death you can have a bank
account you can have a mortgage but i
was too impersonal no
no
at some point that is exactly what the
[ __ ] you wanted so i'm sure you know who
adam levine
it's really unreal how gorgeous you are
it blows my mind i mean i think i'm the
same seeing you in person i was like i'm
[ __ ] you're 50 times harder in person
and so am i okay so they're basically
just going down the rock but doing
oh my god oh my god oh my god oh my god
oh my god
i want to hug you till you die [ __ ]
that's what this is yeah so now she got
ig chlamydia
adam and i were seeing each other for
about a year
after i stopped talking to him over you
know a period of months this is uh
how he came back into my life
okay serious question
i'm having another baby and if it's
and if it's a boy
i really want to name it summer are you
okay with that dead serious
and then you put a shrug face
carry on
out of all the name
oh
the whole celebrity is sometimes
how many sorry about that let's start on
point one
y'all just naming boys summer now is
that a thing
i'm not going there no am i crazy i
thought summer was a ladies name listen
you know you know whenever it is it's
like when i heard autumn that's a lady's
name you know whatever whenever they
talk about oh black people you got a
weird ass name you got weird names
what's her name oh it's november
september april march crystal waters
i was like
i'm in hell like i have to be in hell at
this point i mean my morals were
unknowingly compromised i was completely
manipulated
girl
hold on
my morals were
unknowingly compromised i was completely
manipulated privately i never wanted to
come forward because obviously i know
the implications that come with doing
what i do making money the way i do and
being an instagram model
um so being tied to a story like this
it's like i know the stereotypes i had
sent um
i'd sent some screenshots recklessly to
a few friends i thought i trusted and
one of them had attempted to sell
to a tabloid
so here i am
that's very convenient
so
the reason why you exposed him is you
felt like it was going to get exposed
anyway so you want to come out in front
of it hey maybe she's telling the truth
maybe not what i do know
is homegirl got her only fence
this [ __ ] been out for a few hours and
already got over 200k likes
and
millions of views
now
maybe he's a friend
or
maybe it's for only fans this girl
talked about she was manipulated she was
too young boo boo this happened a couple
months back okay
less than a year ago
what did you just change overall listen
let's i grant you okay the brain doesn't
develop fully till 25. what the [ __ ]
the difference between 22 and 23
and if you really think that she all of
a sudden got way smarter within a year
and now she can see the light
i could see clean up then the rain is
now come on bro what are we talking
about right now
what are we talking about right now
listen lady
you [ __ ] with a married man knowing damn
well he was married
you did that this is why i don't like
when people come out with these exposed
stories they never mention any
accountability for themselves no
everything is about how these people
[ __ ] down everything is about what these
people are doing
always
never like oh you know what i sought
this out i wanted this no it's all about
they manipulated me they lied to me they
gasped at me all this stuff
like no you don't get my sympathy for
what reason the only person who suffered
this is the child who has to find out
that his dad named him after his
mistress
which is super [ __ ] weird
like not even his daughter his son
that's weird hey son i named you after
the [ __ ] i was cheating on you my wife
with
your mom you know whatever hoes and [ __ ]
that's weird
i feel bad for that nick
cause somebody gonna play this to him in
class hey yo summer do you know what
your dad was doing that summer
i know what you did that summer
i know what your dad did last summer
that's an old movie
and i feel bad for the mom who's got to
be embroiled in the fact that she
married to a 40 year old nia here
tricking with [ __ ] 20 year old models
on ig
and that
her seed that she's about to birth
is going to be named after the mistress
that he was what that's crazy that's
messy and so adam got to take a whole
bunch of else a whole bunch of help i
talked about this lady and you think
adam is going scots-free yeah no
no adam you don't get to do that and b
scott's free that's a whole lot of elves
that's a whole lot of else but then
again you know what
it's not because you're famous it's not
because you got fame that you ain't got
no mental issues and you gotta address
that that's yes that's all right that's
all right same thing
people don't put people on bed on a
pedestal we all have our issues all have
are issues so it is what it is but you
take it out for that one go back to the
menu out of all the names adam out of
all the names
god damn there got to be something just
say the truth
you were [ __ ] with a married dude and
you didn't give a [ __ ] about the other
[ __ ] that's fine because at the end of
the day he's the one who made the
commitment to her so he's the one who
really cheated he's the one who's most
at fault but i'm just tired all these
ladies engaging all this stuff and then
doing this whole fake empathy for the
woman involved and how you were no you
did what you did because you wanted that
good good and that's fine but it's the
same thing with that pastor from that
mega church from um from justin bieber's
mega church yeah he had an affair the
woman comes out and then she gets up on
on good morning america saying a bunch
of goofy [ __ ] like oh
the woman asked her straight up
the woman asks her
did you mess with him knowing he was in
a relationship
but kareem says lentz's rising celebrity
may have contributed to his behavior
when you give somebody so much power
no no no no i don't want to hear it i
don't want to hear it i do not want to
hear it when you give someone so much
power i do not want to hear it
i i can't understand that yet there's
some power dynamics you you're the one
that gives the power stop stop stop you
knew what you were doing stop
stop
it's okay
it's okay that you wanted the the bamboo
you wanted that
and it's
an engagement
it happens it's fine
but take it
take it take it the way you took that
dick
i know that you've said that you have
already gotten
hate and people who are upset with
your choices even for having the affair
with carl in the beginning knowing that
he was married is there anything that
you would like her to know anything you
would like to say to her if she were to
listen i feel bad for her you know woman
to a woman i don't think she she
deserved to to be hurt
the way that she did and um
i i never meant to hurt her
no you never hold on but i i understand
what you're saying she never meant to
hurt her
she never that was not the meaning i
believed that's not that was not that
she was not meaningfully went in there
but you didn't care
and it's fine
it's fine hold up but did i answer to
that question no no no no no no is there
something is there something that you
want to say it doesn't matter just say
no just say no there's nothing i want to
say this whole idea like you engaged in
this knowing damn well it was gonna hurt
her
i didn't mean to you engaged in that
action that could only lead to her being
hurt
just say that you didn't care don't the
guy doesn't go scot-free in that that's
fine
no he owns that he owes the hell he was
the biggest the biggest one yeah but
don't go i really wish she wasn't hurt
you didn't care it's and it's fine you
didn't you did not care no you didn't
care that spirit he's like man whatever
this is why people like oh but you must
have messed with i never ever in my
entire life ever [ __ ] with nobody
married nobody in relationship nobody
even involved in nothing like that i've
had people in those kinds of dynamics
hit me up i'm like listen holla at me
when you single but don't be in my dm is
even talking to me
don't even talk to me i don't want to
catch a bullet no for what [ __ ] i
didn't even [ __ ] that's crazy i should
have taken the affair if i'm gonna die
[ __ ] getting mad at me talk about why
you talk i didn't talk to your wife i
got a dm when was it last reply to
stupid
but [ __ ] in relationship are crazy so
i'm not going to touch nobody no thank
you
no it's just unnecessary drama i know
what it is i don't even have
conversations with them that are
flirtatious because i already know the
implication so all these people talking
about like i didn't mean you knew damn
well what you did you just didn't care
because you want to feel good which is
fine do it but don't come here after the
fact
talk about
no you lose me you lose me i'm just
saying
if you gotta if you gotta do whatever
you gotta do do it
but after that don't don't come up and
say that you care don't come up because
i really wish her well and i you didn't
give me it's fine and it's fine it's
fine it's fine just it was you know
while on camera you don't you know
whatever you want to look a certain way
and stuff like that but it's fine it's
really fun and as far as adam levine
goes like yeah you got to hold that up
but you know this is also something
that's really weird okay we are
you guys watching regular people okay
simple lives to some degree
this is what rich people do this is what
the ultra famous do
and how about i tell you this
more than likely she's going to stay
with adam
some of these wives even know about
these affairs and know about a lot of
this [ __ ] happening the reason why it's
a problem when it gets out is a pr
standard yeah
even though these husbands and wives may
have these understandings between each
other about the man can step out the
women blah blah blah
when it gets out to the public it's just
a bad pr image because they have like
the public has a view of adam of being
like this whole but if you know his
history or you know maroon's fighting
history they all cheat they're all been
very adulterous and done a bunch of
crazy [ __ ] okay rock stars it's none of
my business fidelity you know it's none
of my business
oil and water you feel me
it's not my business
agreed it's not in my business but it's
important but you decide y'all
[ __ ] sometimes decide to share
and to put [ __ ] out there it's not about
none of it is my business but
even though i don't know the particular
relationship dynamics i don't care
mm-hmm
naming your son after your mistress is
crazy that's great hold that up that's
crazy
that's crazy by any standard you could
be [ __ ] supreme leader of the world
that's [ __ ] crazy
yeah and now the lady in in question i'm
talking about uh adam's life
she can't call her son that
his wife is not stupid
his wife knows damn well he out here
cheating left right center
but she probably didn't sign up for this
[ __ ] that's that's that's the most
incriminating another level yeah yeah
yeah yeah that's crazy that's crazy
anyways about us let us know what you
guys think